create something worth sharing a lot of
entrepreneurs come to me and they're
asked me for marketing strategies and
promotion strategies and how do I get
people to talk about me and you know
there are definitely strategies you can
use but at the core of everything has to
be a product or service that people want
to talk about that is worth sharing
because the best marketing strategy in
the world won't save you if you don't
have something that people actually like
and is beneficial and people want to
talk about so as an example recently
Floyd Mayweather posted on his blog a
video that we made we did the top 10
video series on Floyd Mayweather it was
a request I forget who was from and it
got to him right I didn't write the
Floyd Mayweather I didn't say hey Floyd
buddy homie you mind posting this on
your blog but it was so good that he
found it or some of his people found the
or somebody saw and said hey Floyd you
got to check this out and it got posted
to his block right because it was so
good you don't need to have the crazy
marketing strategies when you have a
product or service that people want to
talk about so is your product or service
that good is it something that when
people experience it they want to take
the social media and share it when they
buy it they want to tell their friends
about it because they've gotten such an
amazing result from it right is your
product or service worth sharing so the
question I have for you guys today is
I'm curious to find out when was the
last time somebody shared your product
or service and what was the context tell
me the story leaving the comments below
I'm going to join the discussion thank
you for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon